You ever had a craving
that you can't stop thinking about until you actually have it?
I've been craving Boba for so long
that I just decided to make it today.
Combine some brown sugar and water,
let that heat up
before adding in some tapioca starch and black food coloring,
and then return that to the stove until it thickens up
before adding the rest of my tapioca starch.
Once that was all combined,
I poured it onto my counter
and started kneading it until it all came together,
then split my dough into just so it's easier to handle
and rolled it out
for cutting it in smaller pieces and rolling those into balls.
You can make them as big or as small as you want.
I made them a little smaller
because I knew that they were gonna expand
once I boiled them.
My dough was rolled out into balls.
I transferred them over to boiling water
and let them boil for about 15 minutes
while I got started on steeping my roybus tea.
Right before my pearls were done cooking,
I heated up some brown sugar and for them over.
Once they were all coated in the brown sugar,
I poured them into my glass,
top them with some ice, and my roybis tea.
I obviously needed a splash of milk, and this hit the spot.
It was so much better than store bought Boba.